well the pro-gun right has gone
absolutely nuts after the assassination
of the former japanese prime minister
shinzo abe now the assassination itself
is a major major political story uh it's
been widely covered over the last three
days and there's not so much to add
about that it's a
story of global significance and
japanese significance etc and most of
what there is to say about that has been
said i want to focus on the reaction to
this assassination which was done with a
firearm from the pro-gun right in the
united states who has rallied around
this assassination to say look
gun control is strict in japan
and a former prime minister
was assassinated and this proves that it
doesn't matter what you do in terms of
guns this proves that restricting guns
doesn't make a difference and of course
they're completely wrong and we're going
to look at the data and we're going to
make an empirical case for why that is
now just to sort of set the stage
um
what we have learned about this
assassination this is per npr
um political motivations have been
denied by the shooter he told police the
attack had been planned for months abe
was shot from behind in the western city
of nara while speaking at a campaign
event police arrested tatsuya yamagami a
41 year old at the scene yamagami uh an
unemployed former sailor in the maritime
armed forces of japan confessed to the
killing for which he used a handmade
firearm according to police and that's
an element
of the reaction that we are hearing from
many which is look even if you restrict
firearms completely to the point of
making them illegal people will just
make them at home and we're going to get
back to that but the most important top
line thing to understand
is that although there has been
a killing this is you know last week we
had this caller who said david why why
aren't anecdotes okay
to understand the world around us
anecdotes are our experience and the
point i made was
if you extrapolate from an anecdote you
often will be wrong and the fact that
someone was killed with a gun in japan
misses the reality that the rate of gun
death in japan is a fraction of what it
is in the united states the numbers are
actually quite stunning
two important uh bits of data first of
all
very few people own guns in japan and i
think
no nobody denies that part in the u.s
there's an estimate of 120 guns per 100
people that that's more than one gun per
person in the united states whereas in
japan it's 0.3 guns per 100 people so
that's the gun ownership rate and then
if you continue in looking at this bbc
article you see that gun deaths in japan
are extremely rare in the us there are
seven deaths
by firearm per 100 thousand people
whereas in japan it's 0.03
japan's rate of gun death
is um a fraction and in fact the u.s
rate of gun death is 23 000 higher than
the rate in japan that's not a typo 23
000
higher so then you go to well
the person made the gun at home
so you can't prevent that well imagine
if the only way to shoot someone was to
make the gun at home think about that if
you could if that was really the way if
you wanted to shoot someone you had to
make a firearm in your house
imagine how much lower gun violence
would be because most people aren't
going to do that
guns are not illegal in japan they're
just much more difficult to obtain and
this has worked at making the gun
violence the gun death rate almost zero
if to buy a gun in japan you need to
take a firearms class
pass a written exam which is only held
three times a year so you can't just say
well i want it tomorrow you it's held
three times a year you've got to get a
doctor's note uh saying you're mentally
fit and have no history of drug abuse
you have to ask for a permit
to do firing training that can take a
month you have to be interviewed by
police and explain why you need a gun
you have to pass a review of your
criminal history and gun possession
record employment involvement with
organized crime debt relationships with
friends all these things you then apply
for a gun powder permit you take a one
day training class have to pass a firing
test at that point you can get a
certificate from a gun dealer describing
the gun that you want if you are trying
to hunt you have to get a hunting
license to show i'm really getting this
in order to hunt you then have to get a
gun safe and an ammo locker the police
have to inspect it and make sure that
it's in compliance you then do a final
kind of overall background review and
after that step 13 or 18 depending on
whether you consider each of these
things one or sometimes two things then
you can actually go and buy a gun
so the anecdotal reaction this is the
this is the epitome of why anecdotes
aren't useful the anecdotal reaction is
strict gun laws
and there's a shooting
none of the gun laws work
the systemic empirical reaction is
strict gun laws
very small rate of gun ownership guns
aren't illegal but all of this leads to
a tiny tiny rate of gun death in the
country of japan yes
a person was killed with a gun and it
was notable and it was a known person
because it's a former prime minister
it's like if bill clinton or george w
bush were uh or donald trump were killed
with a firearm it is notable it's major
news
but the gun violence rate is nothing in
japan compared to that of the united
states and that really should be the big
takeaway so
i was involved in a whole bunch of
different twitter spats as this was
going on with people saying this this
proves that you can't prevent gun
violence no actually this proves that
you can and in fact this story is a
major story in japan not only because of
the person that was killed the former
prime minister but because anyone was
killed with a gun at all because it is
so rare
in the entire country and japan has a
large population i think it's about 80
80 million
um
you have to adjust for that it's smaller
than the u.s but that rate is tiny for a
country with so many people and in fact
let me just double check
japan population 125 million actually so
it's an even even bigger country making
the the number of gun deaths even
smaller that's the takeaway their policy
has worked